voilà donc en fait on a les gaz chauds
qui sortent de la
pur Christian pontonnier travaille
depuis 32 ans dans les chauffages
urbains depuis 6 ans il exerce sur le
site de versaill un lieu caché qui
ouvrira au public lors des journées du
patrimoine en avant-première Christian
pontonnier nous emmène en visite
guidée on a donc TR chaudières pour le
chauffage urbain C trois chaudières
gaz qui nous permettent d'assurer la
production de chauffage et d'eau chaude
sanitaire sur l'ensemble de chauffages
urbain aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître la chaufferie versaillaise
participe depuis 3 ans aux Journées du
Patrimoine le site industriel se
distingue ainsi des dorures historiques
proposé par la ville je crois que les
gens actuellement sont très intéressés
justement par des sites industriel et
puis il faut bien savoir que cette
chaufferie fait partie du patrimoine de
la la ville puisqu'elle appartient à la
ville de Versailles il était donc normal
de l'ouvrir de façon à ce que les
Versaillais et tous les autres puissent
venir la visiter et parmi les nouveautés
de l'année 2012 cette turbine à gaz qui
fonctionne 5 mois par an et produit
95000 MW cette machine ne fonctionne que
5 mois par ça c'est une turbine et
l'ensemble du système c'est un système
de
cogénération la société de chauffage
versé au succursal de cofé dispose d'un
réseau de 27 km pour 90 point de
livraison d'énergie elle alimente le
centre de Versailles et le plateau de
satori le public pourra découvrir le
site industriel samedi 15 septembre de
10h à 16h30 pour les journées du
patrimoine